i just really love
love therefore i am the matchmaker i'm
laura hi i'm chris i feel like you can
tell a lot about a guy just based on his
amazon purchases today i want you to
look through the amazon histories of
three different single guys and then
decide who you are going on a date with
yeah sounds good yeah yeah cool
hey i'm ethan hi i'm john hey i'm ken do
you feel like amazon orders say a lot
about a person yeah what can you find
out about something it's sort of like
unfiltered and like you sort of see like
their weird niches and things like that
yeah i feel good about it like i feel
really confident in my in my order i
really do you think it actually reflects
who you guys are as people i think so
yeah for sure i think they can come to
pretty good conclusions what do you feel
like you can tell from a guy just based
on that maybe like part of their
lifestyle like what they like what they
need you're expecting a guy to just have
what what what's going to be in his
history like toothbrushes toothbrushes i
don't know
advil maybe like impulse purchases too
and what's a red flag maybe like star
wars themed stuff um i feel like that's
i don't know i hear people clicking the
dislike
sorry an attractive guy that you wanna
date like what does he do what does he
like i guess someone who's like pretty
active someone who likes to move and
doesn't like staying at home like all
the time maybe so let's see if she did a
good job of of figuring you guys out
dell u series 32-inch screen led lit
monitor you want to count it it's like
big like this yeah whoa that's like a tv
what does that say about him he has a
really poor eyesight or something poor
eyesight yeah
are you into more curved screen type
guys or more flat screen type guys i
think flats what's your type i feel like
curved screen sounds a little
pretentious and unnecessary you got like
three screens at work just i just use
one really big one it's curved
you know that one you know that lady who
does like the math in her head like i'm
just trying to figure out what angle
you're talking about guy one item two
fire away katan board game extension i
like katan so this is a plus all right
okay but it is a pretty long game so
this means that the guy is patient
which i like i think that's a plus for
me all right so so far looking good for
this guy right pure drive tour tennis
racket this means he plays tennis he's
active
he's athletic
i wonder where he plays there's not a
lot of room in the city where do you
think he lives based on this maybe like
queens
or brooklyn do we like brooklyn guys do
you like queens guys they're all right
i'm a queens girl so i thought we're
going like a good six out of ten right
now i'm surviving but i'm not striving i
mean the next two could make your six
lip tone 12-inch mirror ball hanging
disco lighting ball for dj club stage
bar party wedding holiday decoration
where do you think he's putting this
hopefully in his bedroom she can't
handle that maybe maybe she's not my
type wait where is the disco ball in the
living room in the living room i could
see in the shower though this guy knows
how to have fun dog chew toys toothbrush
stick so it's a cactus chewing dog toy
cute maybe he has a puppy is that is
that what puppies do they chew on things
i think so oh sorry yeah i think they do
i think they do he obviously has a dog
there's no maybe no one's buying this
for themselves right
well how do you know yeah it's your
aspect you're right good point just for
personal use
no dog involved i mean i was a jacob
girl for toilet anyway so oh okay so
this is this helps plus pella cocktail
company habanero margarita mixer 750
milligrams to go with the disco ball i
don't know what to say about this i
don't i don't really make mixed drinks
or cocktails huge red flag
what do you drink next thing is miracle
grow water soluble all-purpose plant
food eight ounces
that's a closer right there he cares
about growth
here into the very depths of this man's
soul and tell me what you find it seems
like this guy knows how to have fun
margarita board games disco ball he
knows how to party just at a party and
he cares about his dog and his plants
yeah he's like committed committing to
the plant he's committing to the plants
and to games of catan sounds like a
winner yeah i think that all right
that's pretty good that's pretty good
that's solid i hope chris backs me up
like that
guy number two air fryer max extra large
cooker extra large sounds pretty large
so maybe he bakes
sounds kind of fancy she says fancy
what's fancier than air fryer
two air fryers yeah maybe he like cooks
like a whole ass like rotisserie chicken
or something is that a turn on for a guy
if he's making a full rotisserie chicken
if it's all for me yeah second one is
two-piece mechanical pencils point five
and point seven you're really reading
the whole thing because there's like
there's like stuff in here you use a
pencil still the hardest i like to draw
oh okay you i think get along with this
right because you're into art right yeah
yeah yeah i don't like point seven
millimeter pencils though maybe he wants
variety yeah he wants to try it out so
this guy is adventurous but why pencils
why not pens i like to erase and make
mistakes or maybe makes a lot of
mistakes i need to erase i don't know
about this guy okay pepsid maximum
strength for heartburn prevention and
relief maximum strength 75 count that's
a lot of pepsi that's a commitment
that's coming that's a commitment you
take pepsi after you have like heartburn
or before you drink and you're asian or
you have like the asian flush right so
you take it so you don't get red exactly
he's bringing the the stuff to the party
that everyone else like forgets about
because they're focused on the
margaritas that's true maybe this guy is
like holding it together for everyone do
you get asian flush
um only if i have a lot
he got me just just in case
yeah
yeah
yeah after i eat the whole rotisserie
chicken i'm gonna need that pepsi
phillips you play white in color smart
light guy takes you home and you go into
his room and he's like hey alexa turn on
spicy lights or whatever kind of like
that's happening yeah i actually have a
sex mode
i do never used it never used it cannot
wait to use it i wonder why like why why
do you why would you want that look nice
this guy sounds like he has to change it
up she liked to discoverable there's no
reason for this
yeah
you like seeing like it's a little
creepy you know i should have got this
sex mode and stuff like that you know
pachycara scentsy tech composite
volleyball so he plays a team sport
probably right so it gets along with
other people seems pretty athletic i
mean i watched a volleyball anime i
think it's pretty cool i love the anime
cosplay prop for thor's model hammer
what does this mean it's thor's hammer
oh it's just a hammer it's not like a no
it's an outfit it looks like just thor's
hammer
why i feel powerful holding it
it's like a fidget toy kind of except a
hammer it seems like he's like a marvel
buff good for you get what you want you
got money right weird weird conclusion
but hammer means money guys segway
electric excluder lightweight those are
fun those are fun it's fast right maybe
you commute somewhere with it you gotta
get one change your life i think people
who ride electric squinters are pretty
cool you're going good
i think so yeah i feel like they both
seem responsible they treat themselves
too all right so this is guy number
three item one we got katana again so
patient and i think katan is also like
unflavored protein powder it's lactose
free though asian
maybe an asian that's correct yeah i'm
lactose intolerant
well this shows a lot of commitment
because if you have a flavor you'll get
sick of it eventually whereas this one
yeah you use it forever exactly he's in
it for the long game he infuses for
loose tea if he uses like an infuser
that means he has loose leaf tea in his
house correct i take my tea seriously
yeah i grew up in uk so like you know i
take my teeth very seriously i mean he
has a lot of patience because he's
willing to sit by and let tea steep
super premium short green rice i
actually just bought this brand
excellent yeah
yeah there you go
15 pounds is a lot of a lot of rice
commitment commitment commitment
commitment and this is like premium rice
too so he's bougie or like he likes to
treat himself where it matters allow
your diet healthy body healthy soul
healthy mind and disc 128 pro sd card
128 is a lot that's probably from video
then do you think he does like youtube
videos is he like an influencer i think
i think it might be a good thing sounds
like someone who maybe likes to document
stuff so he can look back maybe later on
that could be true that could be true
dixie heavyweight disposable cutlery so
maybe he goes on a lot of picnics or he
just doesn't like washing dishes god
i don't know but you're creating waste
how dare you luggage expandable suitcase
28 inch so this guy seems like he likes
to travel you like a jet setter guy that
guy who moves around oh if he brings me
yeah okay
there's like a lot of overlap you know
with the katan especially that was kind
of unexpected but what it tells me is
that all of these guys have friends they
want to play with so of the three guys
is there any guy that you don't want to
go out with the third guy maybe it's
like the plastic forks we don't like
plastic fork guys plastic forks with the
second guy he ordered a lot of things
that make me think that he's like a tech
guy but the other guy i mean it depends
on where he has the disco ball i think
for me i need to know worth a date to
find out right yeah i would say so i'm
gonna go with dog owning plant owning
tennis playing flat screen owning guy
number one you ready to meet him sure
yeah let's do it all right
laura now that you've seen their order
history do you have anything to say to
all of them y'all like katan oh yeah
we're gonna play after this the four of
us it's gonna be like a battle royale
well you picked ethan nice to meet you
was she pretty right in her analysis of
you yeah yeah i think so like fun
exciting interesting we're gonna
actually cut the cameras off for a
little bit and you guys can go off on
your little mini dick and then we'll
come back in and check in and see what
you guys want to do after that okay
[Music]
so are you doing another date yeah she's
open for it where are you taking me
probably somewhere in manhattan probably
probably not queens maybe like a bar did
anything surprise you after you seeing
his amazon orders yeah he doesn't have a
dog my brother has a dog we were hoping
it was just your chew toy oh yeah yeah
that'd be kinky when's the wedding we're
gonna ride out love is blind the bats
the bachelor we need to like milk the
whole thing first and then
outside of the date you guys all need to
play catan now and we'll just drink
margaritas yeah we'll air fry dinner
together with the disco ball in the back
this was fun thank you everyone for
doing this it was a pleasure
[Music]
[Music]
you